I'm going to be talking a lot more about this
in the next few weeks, but I want to sort
of get us thinking about this.
We are now past the point of no return with
Corona virus in terms of the timing of the
election.
Let me explain what I mean by that.
It takes somewhere in the range of eight to
10 weeks to flatten the case curve.
If you lock down today.
Right.
Which means that if Florida, Arizona, these
states that are imploding, if they did a full
lockdown today, you would probably not see
the effect of that.
You wouldn't see the cases come under control
and talk tober first.
But in addition to that, deaths lagged by
20 days.
So if we saw a lockdown today, you wouldn't
really see some of these states get the outbreak
under control until late October.
OK.
So when you know that when you see 15000 cases
a day in Florida and death records in Florida,
the timeline of how the virus works, we saw
it in New York.
We know how long it takes.
It means that there will be a huge corona
virus problem in some of these key states,
including Florida, which will be so important
for the November election.
It's going to be going on in mid-October in
the best case scenario.
And that's if states locked down, they don't
even seem interested in locking down.
What that tells us is Trump can't rely on
winning in November because the virus is under
control.
Just mathematically, it's not going to happen.
This means they only have dirty tricks left.
And Andy Croll wrote a really good article
in Rolling Stone outlining the techniques
that Republicans and Trump are going to use
to try to win.
One technique is going to be using lawsuits
to wreak havoc in February.
The Trump campaign, as Andy Crow writes, and
the Republican National Committee announced
they were going to spend 10 million dollars
filing voted voting related lawsuits in 2020
in Pennsylvania, for example.
They sued the state government of Pennsylvania
and election boards in every county to ban
the use of secure drop boxes for submitting
Take-Home ballots.
And they said that pollwatchers can only serve
in the county where they live, which is a
great way to if you have a county without
a highly engaged population, you would want
to bring in poll watchers from other counties
that won't be allowed.
It's a great way to allow intimidation at
the ballot box.
They're going to be working to block ballots,
including ballots submitted by mail.
They're going to be working on intimidating
voters.
They will be spreading disinformation.
They're going to be working to prevent absentee
ballot expansions altogether.
And we've seen Donald Trump doing that for
months already.
They're going to use bogus fears of voter
fraud to justify whatever they can get away
with.
So none of these techniques are new.
But the point is they don't have any more.
The idea of, hey, you know what our strategy
will be?
We'll do a little voter suppression because
we always do it.
But we'll also make a case that we have dealt
with the virus and we fixed the economy.
Trump sort of still continues to claim that
he's dealing with the virus well.
But the math of it shows a different reality.
And the cases are going to be raging for eight
to 10 weeks in the best case scenario in some
of these states.
So all they have left are the dirty tricks.
I'm going to be doing much more extensive
coverage of this.
And my goal is we all need to be prepared
for what they are likely to do.
We need to expect what they are going to do.
We need to have a plan to fight it.
We are going to be talking about how you can
get involved as an election monitor.
I mean, there are things depending on state
laws that you can actually do and get involved
in.
But this has to be our focus now because they're
out of actual policy arguments.
Trump hasn't even talked about policy in any
way for weeks other than saying we're going
to do more of the great stuff in the second
term that I did in the first term, even though
it didn't really happen in the first term.
And in any case, it's the fault of the Corona
virus or Democrats or Obama or who?
Jimmy Carter.
I mean, he'll blame anybody, right?
All they have left their dirty tricks.
And that's why this is so important.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
David Pakman.
For the latest updates on all of this.
We're going to take a quick break.
And it's just a beautiful Friday show for
you today.